ein wunderschöner mittag erwartet uns
hier auf unserer kleinen map in
minecraft meine lieben freunde wir haben
für heute einen riesigen plan und zwar
die automatische weizen fahren
das hat sich gereimt auf plan das erste
was ich benötige beziehungsweise nicht
richtig benötige sondern dafür auf jeden
fall nutzen möchte sind laternen das
haben wir ganz ganz viele von euch in
die kommentare geschrieben das ist schon
ganz lange laterne minecraft gibt die
sind richtig schön aus wir brauchen auf
jeden fall noch drei weitere von den
laternen nämlich insgesamt sechs stück
die kann ich von meiner liste schon mal
abhaken ich glaube ich war noch nie so
vorbereitet für ein video den sie können
später zum ersten mal regnet auf unserer
insel das zuckerrohr hier vorne kann ich
auch schon mal fällen und ein bisschen
neu hier hinsetzen am rand damit wir das
die ganze zeit sich vermehren lassen
können zack zack zack zack noch mal
vielleicht ein bisschen auf der anderen
seite kann man ihr im wasser liegt auch
noch was während ich gleich übrigens die
weizen fahren baue habe ich auch ein
kleines thema vorbereitet das finde ich
glaube ich ein bisschen interessanter
als das sie mir einfach beim dingen kann
das hier wachsen ist glaube ich ein
bisschen interessanter
[Musik]
er nervt ja aber da kann ich ja nichts
für eine kiste reich denke ich erst mal
da noch einige redstone fackeln und zwar
insgesamt 123 verdammt alter wir
brauchen echtholz ich brauche auch
einfach steine ich glaube erst mal
wirklich am meisten sinn wenn ich meine
liste hier abarbeite euch da eine kleine
times ein blender und dann sehen wir uns
wieder wenn ich fertig bin
[Musik]
wir sind fertig ich würde sagen dass wir
einfach mal hier vorne runter gehen
ich hatte erst überlegt das ganze im
dingen zu machen in meinem keller
einfach von dem haus allerdings macht es
hier glaube ich ein bisschen mehr sinn
und die sache ist dass wir jetzt hier
erstmal wirklich eine menge menge steine
abtragen müssen ich habe mir hier links
wirklich in photoshop so ein kleines
feld aufgezeichnet wie ich das ganze
bauen möchte von daher werden wir jetzt
hier wirklich eine kleine mining folge
machen also macht das video einfach an
lass uns laufen und ich was zu trinken
was zu essen und hört mir einfach ein
bisschen zu oder wir machen es
ermöglicht ob das will kein mensch ich
habe vor heute eine kleine geschichte
vorbereitet meine lieben freunde
beziehungsweise keine richtige
geschichte sondern vielmehr eine kleine
real life story und eine story ist auch
eine geschichte und diese geschichte hat
mit unserem freund und helfer der
polizei zu tun hier denkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich blue card irgendwie eine
anzeige bekommen oder in wien menschen
verletzt oder keine ahnung was nina also
in die richtung geht es gar nicht ich
hatte nur in der letzten woche zwei mal
kontakt mit der polizei und so viel
kontakt mit der polizei hatte ich in
meinem ganzen leben nicht so richtig ich
nehme es allerdings erst mal ganz kurz
die wassereimer und bei uns hier eine
unendliche wasser quell der profi ich
hatte in der letzten woche zwei mal
etwas mit der polizei zu tun und fragt
sie jetzt vielleicht erst mal so hell
wie konnte das stande lokal bislang
eigentlich ein ganz vernünftiger junge
ja die sache ist dass das ein bisschen
komisch war uns war bin ich an der
alster hergelaufen und ein polizist hat
mich dann angesprochen und meinte hey
maske auf und ich denke mir nur so hey
ich bin am joggen so ich bin ja jetzt ja
nicht irgendwo der stadt oder so
allerdings muss man jetzt wirklich in
dem bereich um die ich kann mich
überhaupt nicht konzentrieren hier
gerade ich bin so was und ich
multitaskingfähig auf jeden fall war ich
dort unterwegs und der polizist meinte
ja hier ist jetzt masken pflicht an der
an der alster und ich hatte ein bisschen
mit ihm geredet und sein kollege dachte
dann irgendwie ich wäre mit ihm
diskutieren so von wegen ich muss eine
strafe zahlen oder keine ahnung was ich
wusste das nicht von irgendwoher
mitbekommen dass ihr mann der all star
sehen wie eine maske tragen muss kann
sein kollege meinte gibbs dem problem
und sein kollege mit dem ich mich dann
unterhalten wie wir haben uns ganz gut
unterhalten und hat halt gefragt warum
und wieso weshalb so klar wegen corona
aber genau so ein bisschen gequatscht
und das war meine erste situation der
polizei man denkt jetzt vielleicht
erstmal so gut wie gar nichts krasses ja
bei mir war das allerdings ist das im
kopf denn diese werbung radio geht ins
ohr bleibt im kopf friedrich die auf
zwei tage später einen kumpel war bei
mir und wir haben gekocht und so haben
dinge gemacht mit ein lachsfilet
generell seitdem ich in hamburg wohne
bin ich ein richtiger lachs fan geworden
oder fisch fan generell und da war es
dann auf jeden fall so dass kollege da
war und
wir hatten halt mit den musikern haben
gekocht und so und dann noch ein spiel
gespielt das spiel war had melden also
die hitman nicht kennen da geht es darum
dass man sein agent ist man muss
irgendwie halt leute töten und man hat
ganz ganz wenige missionen die mission
die man allerdings hat sind extrem
extrem langweilig kann auch was extrem
lang ist aber auf jeden fall gibt es bei
hitman eine mysteriöse ist so dumm wie
kann es eigentlich kaum erzählen
es gibt eine mission bei hitman also
hätten drei das neue spiel für
playstation 5 damit geht ein
die spielt in berlin in seinem club in
berlin natürlich klar berlin ist wieder
mit einem club dargestellt paris wurde
ja nicht mehr in zwei oder hitman einst
so richtig schön im schönen haus und
england wird auch mit so nachricht die
schönen verlassen den fehler dargestellt
berlin so richtig ekelhaft im wald mit
einer tankstelle und dem klub irgendwie
so bei köln noch nicht anfangen zu bauen
denn wir brauchen die erst mal das was
da noch so richtig auf jeden fall war
mir am kochen und haben nebenbei hat so
ein bisschen hinten an gespielt und es
gibt bei hippen inhalt dieser eine
mission in berlin im club ist es auf
jeden fall wirklich sehr sehr
detailgetreu und die haben dort auch
nicht irgendwie so komische game music
dann im hintergrund sondern halt
wirklich wirklich krank ist dj set
irgendwie da abspielen lassen und wir
natürlich am kochen und unterhalten
haben nebenbei allerdings gespielt hat
mehr mit der mission und so weiter und
so fort
und dann war es halt wirklich so dass
einfach die polizei bei mir geklingelt
hat in der annahme dass bei mir eine
corona party stattfindet
die zeit hat geklingelt und man denkt
natürlich im ersten moment immer so ein
bisschen moment mache ich kann irgendwas
falsch
also bei mir ist es zumindest du auch
wenn ich im straßenverkehr unterwegs bin
und ich sehr war nur polizeiauto fährt
an mir vorbei ich habe instant richtig
schiss und kontrolliert so alles bin ich
wirklich angeschnallt sitzen sich gerade
im auto wenn ihr neben einer ampel
stehen ich war extra ein schulterblick
und so weiter und so fort also da bin
ich wirklich sehr sehr penibel genau
dass ich auf alles achte und das ding
war dann einfach ich habe mir geklingelt
und dann hoch gekommen
im haus und so anhand von meiner wohnung
und haben dann ganze zeit gefragt dürfen
mal kurz rein kommen ich hab dann
natürlich freundlich wie immer gesagt ja
natürlich ich komme so rein schauen sie
bald ein kumpel von mir da und herd war
an mit mit einer vorne drauf und so
weiter und so fort ich brauch dass man
eben erst ganz kurz zu und dann haben
sie direkt der kantara ok alles in
ordnung und dann hab ich halt trotzdem
mal so gefragt warum man sie denn jetzt
hier ja wir hatten annahme dass in der
korona party stattfindet nachbarn haben
bescheid gesagt dass bei ihnen musik ist
und die haben auch es regnet schon
wieder hier rein
es ist hier los
in hamburg fand übrigens in hamburg soll
es morgen schneiden
ich war dann auf jeden fall verdutzt und
habe gefragt
von welchen nachbarn das dann kam die
aussage und meinte nur soja stehen sie
glaube ich selber wolle jetzt nicht
sagen nicht dass du dann genau wissen ok
mit denen es irgendwie blöd ich tanze
aber hätte man dass da nicht irgendwie
auch dass sie einfach klingeln und mal
fragen
der ist ja normalerweise kennen wir das
auch so aber irgendwie war das sie dann
nicht der fall und ich dachte mir
einfach nur so helfer dabei wollen mich
jetzt irgendwie verarschen oder so also
nicht die polizei war meine nachbarn in
dem ich bisher nicht auf kriegsfuß ich
habe mich schon ein bisschen habe ich
mich dann auch doch leider verbaut und
die polizei hat ja alles easy klar es
ist einfach mit dem nachbarn nicht sagen
mit wem denn ja kann ich sagen nicht so
hey und moral von der geschicht hier war
natürlich keine corona party es gibt für
alles regelkonform aber wir haben
einfach nur ein bisschen gekochten
bisschen was getrunken das darf man ja
noch und ein kumpel war wie gesagt bei
mir
und ja das waren die beiden situationen
wo ich wirklich mit der polizei
etwas zu tun hatte in der letzten woche
die sache ist ich sehe schon die ganzen
kommentare herr luca wird sie gar nicht
rein lassen müssen und blabla ja ich
weiß aber wenn ich weiß ich mache ja
nichts falsch
dann koche ich natürlich komplett also
generell es ist deutlich sinnvoller als
dass ich mich irgendwie quer gestellt
hätte ist meine ansicht macht auf jeden
fall mehr sind wenn man da kooperativ
fragen geht an die sache für mich
naja gut auf jeden fall ist jetzt alles
gut nächstes passiert ich schätze ihren
trick dahin und darunter ihr mit kiste
hin und hier zeigt dann haben wir eine
große kiste
der plan ist jetzt dass ich ihr seht ihr
hier sind überall weiteren teile drauf
ich demonstriere das ja kam ich
demonstriere dass ich kann jetzt hier
auf den schalter einfach klicken dann
fließt das was darüber genau bis hierhin
alles sehr nah ja muss ich noch ein
bisschen überlegen aber es soll alles
hier einfallen und dadurch dass hier von
der seite das was man muss auch kommen
dass da hinten kann ich dann auch jetzt
noch mal zu bauen hier so das kommt dann
auf jeden fall alles hier runter und
wird hier in den trichter reingespielt
der trichter spieles direkt in
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich hier vorne das
auch noch zu bauen muss dann müsste ich
nochmal ein bisschen in die planung
gehen bei mir der test hat das geklappt
was gute runter zack zack geht da rein
und
[Musik]
ja gedacht erwartet natürlich ein
creeper direkt auf meiner farm also ich
weiß jetzt nicht genau wo ihr der fehler
liegt das könnt ihr mir vielleicht
morgen in die kommentare schreiben
brauche ich einen zweiten trichter dass
er hier auf die kiste zu greift muss ich
das jetzt zu bauen dann müsste ich aber
den schalter ein bisschen höher setzen
ein bisschen angst hätten hier auch aber
gut meine lieben freunde an der stelle
würde ich die heutige episode minecraft
mit luca jetzt auch beenden wenn euch
diese heute etwas ruhigere folge mal
etwas wenn euch diese heute etwas mal
ruhiger ausgefallene folge gefallen hat
er das gern einen daumen hoch unter
video da schreibt mir gern bitte in die
kommentare was ich hier falsch gemacht
habe das eigentlich läuft auch alles
also das wächst wir haben licht es mit
dem redstone funktioniert muss ich das
hier mit dem wasser irgendwie anders man
schreibe gern und in die kommentare
bewertet das video wenn es euch gefallen
hat abonieren einen kanal was kann ich
noch sagen ich hab' merchandise shop und
eine neue folge minecraft mit luca kommt
übermorgen und 20 uhr schaltet dort
wieder ein